a brand new program debuts later today
noon eastern lunch talk live with mike
tarico and right out of the gates man
he's not wasting any time mike
schuszewski the duke head coach russell
wilson seahawks quarterback chris
collinsworth from sunday night football
and dale earnhardt jr joining us now to
talk about that and other things our
good friend host of football night in
america and pretty much everything else
at nbc it's mike tarico hello mike how
are you
hello guys good morning it's good
watching you here this morning good to
be with you as well yeah we're we're all
sitting around uh in this self-isolation
so we might as well all talk with each
other i figure uh we were all putting
our heads together this will be an hour
distraction if you will from the
important stuff that's happening
elsewhere down the dial obviously all
the news information takes precedence
but we're using sports as an escape
which is what we usually do with sports
so if we can get some folks up and talk
sports and you guys will be on along the
way here uh just spend an hour doing
that get people a little respite from
what's going on maybe we can be a little
bit of service in this difficult time
and mike that's such an important point
and we make that point every day because
i think people can only take so much of
it right they can only take so much of
the news they can only take so much of
the gloom we're human beings we have to
have some balance and that's what we're
trying to do and it's good that you're
going to be on for an hour a day at
lunch time to help people with that
balance
we're trying to do that you know
the syracuse university basketball team
is very close and dear to my heart as an
alum saturday night one of the networks
re-aired the 2003 game where syracuse
won the national championship a bunch of
the players and the coaches got on a
zoom call it was put on facebook live
there are three four thousand people
watching and it was just an escape but
really in the middle of it i forgot
everything else that was going on and
that's what this is the purpose of uh of
our roles of sports and of reality right
now how can we find these little windows
to just let our minds escape from you
know what's really for most of us the
toughest thing certainly is a society
we've dealt with in our lifetimes and uh
for a lot of folks who are 70 80 years
old they said they've never been through
anything like this so we'll try to do
our part we'll have some fun we'll talk
sports and we'll continue to keep folks
updated on when we might see sports
again as you guys were talking today you
know we really have no idea the
realities of how far this is going to go
into the summer and impact the fall
mike i mean what have you been doing in
your free time i mean this time of the
year you'd normally be getting ready for
the kentucky derby and a lot of other
sporting events and i know you you're mr
particular detailed preparation that's
what you do
like give us an inside look to the
torico household during these weird
times
my thumbs are very strong i keep waiting
for you to update the next draft profile
that you have uh
you're finding that's what really is
keeping me going hour to hour sims yeah
no no seriously but that that stuff
helps it all helps uh we were down in
florida after the
golf tournament recovered the players
championship ended a couple of weeks ago
so we did self-isolation down there then
i've come back up to where we live in
michigan and we're just all like
everyone else we're hunkered down we're
settled in one big food shopping in for
the week and uh have all the kids under
one roof and all that fun stuff but
we've been doing a lot of stuff with uh
the beginnings and the ends for these
football weekend america games that
aired last week uh doing some stuff with
the olympians a couple of weeks ago when
the olympics were postponed so certainly
it's been busier than i would have
thought but it's not what we normally do
or the things we typically do so uh just
trying to find ways to stay sane stay
prepared read some more books know those
books that whole big shelf of books back
behind me that i never get to i'm
actually getting to some of those so
just trying to enjoy life and take some
long walks and appreciate the good
things we have and honestly i think
that's part of doing this show a lot of
the people who you watch who cover
sports and who are in the sports arena
are in exactly the same boat as a lot of
the folks at home so we'll share some of
that then uh maybe everybody will feel a
little bit less isolated
and you know mike the nfl has tried its
best to trudge ahead during these
uncertain times free agency opened as
usual the draft is going to happen as
scheduled but today is the day that
there's really an impact for the first
time on the nfl off-season programs were
supposed to open for the teams with new
coaches i don't think there's going to
be any offseason programs for anyone how
do you think that's going to impact the
preparation for a season that is still
up in the air but let's assume there is
a season no off season program that's
going to have a huge effect on what we
ultimately see in the fall
yeah mike every time we think about
something else there's one more layer of
this onion we continue to unpeel you
just brought it up with chris a couple
of segments ago about
the reality of these draft related
trades and without physicals will they
be approved and will those picks be
taken by those teams when the draft
happens in three weeks or so one i was
thinking after reading peter king's
column earlier this morning was how many
teams have new offenses that are
impacted by a change what's those change
what are those changes a head coach
an offensive coordinator and a
quarterback who's new well i did a quick
quick count at least 15 teams i found in
one of those three categories new head
coach new oc new qb we'll probably add a
couple of more with the draft so you're
talking about half the league if there's
anything that changes in the league it's
the intricacies of a new offense a new
play caller a new quarterback and
everybody getting on the same page and
those are reps in time that nobody's
going to have so i think whenever we get
to a season and trust us this is all the
way down at the bottom of the list of
important things right now but whenever
we get down there that's going to be a
significant hindrance you look at a team
like philly they're going to be the only
team in their division coming back with
that nucleus and offense together they
may be at a bit of an offensive
advantage when they get going compared
to other teams it's going to be so
fascinating to see how that plays out we
only hope that we can have those
conversations here in the next two or
three months
but mike are you in the the same
category as me and florio where we're
you know again we know times are tough
but we want to see the draft because we
don't think there's enough out there for
the public to kind of get their heads
away from the bad news out there right
now kind of what's your thoughts on the
nfl kind of going uh forward with the
business as usual
yeah chris i've gone back and forth i i
didn't feel that connection to free
agency that i normally do because you're
so focused on it while other stuff is
going on but with the severity and the
heaviness of the news i couldn't really
get dialed into a lot of those moves
emotionally at least as it's gone on i
think it's taken a place of some of our
attention and time and when you do think
about it from a long-range planning
standpoint and that is something that i
think we've all realized
we all need to be better at in the long
run if you plan to have a season in
september and a normal nfl season
fingers crossed let's hope we can get
there
then you need to do all these steps
along the way when they've done them
free agency the draft and all of that i
know we don't have otas but at least
like you said it's gotten us away from a
little bit of the news it's given us
something to think about and the other
piece of that is if you're going to get
to a place where we can open training
camps in august then you needed to do
all these steps along the way so if it's
insensitive to some understandable but
this might be the right thing to do
well and one way that i've balanced it
mike yes there are tens if not hundreds
of thousands who are physically affected
by
the virus but on the other hand there
are millions who may be suffering the
psychological effects of being cooped up
having nothing to do and this gives
people something to look forward to and
something to fully engage in for three
days coming up later this month all
right we look forward to every weekday
noon eastern lunch talk live with mike
tarico starts today mike thanks for your
time chris uh the hell with you you're
the man
who are you foreign
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports